So in summary, the questions you want to ask are
how big can this be,
how much of it can we get,
what's the growth rate of the market,
is the market itself declining
or is it in flux
or is it taking off?
and most importantly here
is talk to customers and the sales channel,
and next important is
you can get some pretty good market size estimates by
competitive approximation
if it's an existing or resegmented market,
or even if we're going to clone a market outside the US.
Next important is
Wall Street Analytic Reports are great.
Market research firms like Forrester and Gartner
are great,
but something to keep in mind about market research
forecasts going forward.
Market research data is wonderful
on the size of markets in the past,
but if market researchers were great at predicting the future,
they'd actually be running hedge funds,
so one of the things I don't accept from my students is,
"and it's going to be a $40 billion business in the next 7 years."
Well, what's its size now?
Zero.
So therefore, I just don't accept
guesses from a market research firm,
unless you've actually cross validated that
with some really heavy customer input from outside the building.